but I see the logic behind why they
wouldn't care though because
um the problem is now is that
when you're of that age if you're dating
women in and around your age there's a
lot of problems there that the man of
that age doesn't necessarily doesn't
want to deal with I'm not saying again I
wouldn't do that myself but I can see
why they would if you're 51 and you're
trying to date like a 35 Plus year old
that's a hell of a lot of baggage a hell
of a little bodies that you've got to
take into your life whereas if you go
for the 21 to 25 year old she's still
malleable you know and they're easily
mocked that um just to say it
younger women are easier to mold easy to
mold to what you want can I just say but
we're these are 50 year olds that are
dating so therefore they've probably
been through right a relationship and
it's had a breakdown so they as you said
they don't want the drama so they're not
they're not necessarily now dating to
get a new wife they've just they've
probably been through a breakup maybe
they've got children they've got that
baggage themselves and they're not
trying to go into it as you said another
baggage relationship so they're looking
for the the fun like the midlife crisis
reliving their youth before they went
through the messy divorce well that's
one of the reasons why you know older
men tend to not deal with women their
age and also tend to not deal with you
know women who have children
because that baggage
speaking from experience
um that baggage as a woman who's got a
child been through certain things in
life
um it's a lot to take on as a man when
you're just a single man who's probably
you know built up built up what he's
built up and is cool when he's
okay living the life the way he lives it
to bring on somebody with so much
baggage is there's there's no benefit to
it but I have a question for the girls
do you think it's more who do you think
has more like emotional baggage is it
them at that age so let's say they're
both 51 man and a woman who has more
emotional baggage is it the woman or a
man who's like who's more bitter at that
age at 21 not at 20 at that at 50 50.
he's more bits it just depends on the
person I don't think you can I'm saying
generalize it who's more bitter mental
without the care being single broken
down relationship but at that age he's
more bit on men or women probably women
why would you say that
because again we're bathing it's like
this is a holistic yeah yeah because
they may be more likely if they've had
children to be the one that's had ended
up with the children and had to take
that responsibility the man may be
moving out of the marital home maybe
them having to take over the finances
being the single mom feeling like
they've don't have the options maybe
career differences I think women
are more likely to be watching on the
man as well like what's he doing who's
he now dating men bounce back quicker
but I also think men get really
traumatized as do women but because it's
not widely spoken about we just think
that they're not traumatized I think
you've got a good shot yeah I think when
at that age I suppose if you are single
you have got kids you've you've had a
long but you know there's there's a lot
to it than just that so if we know that
then why is it a problem because if
you're saying that women are bitter at
them older ages then why is it a problem
when a man goes through when a man
chooses someone younger I say I think
there's a certain part I think from
sometimes as well as women you know it's
men that go young because they can't get
women their age and I don't think you
can put that down to the women being
beer
we don't want to wait a minute wait a
minute
I'm sorry sorry you're dating a younger
woman aren't you talking about it
um yes I am but and can you not get
women your own age I'm a woman of every
age tell them again big song right now
what'd you say it's harder to attract
women your age or younger women which
one are easier okay so if if you look at
me just it's just easy if you look at me
I can attract generally I can attract
women of all ages
um younger and older okay and that that
is one of the benefits of being a man of
age whereas a woman of age is generally
going to try and attract men of her age
and if she attracts women if she
attracts men of a younger age as we know
it as well they're looking for
experience
it's not for anything long term okay so
yeah like men have that benefit and it's
one of those things that you know a lot
of women try to shame men for they try
to shame and say oh you're going with
these younger girls like I can attract
as a 41 year old man I can attract a 50
year old woman
but I can also attract a 21 year old
woman
but the problem is is that when we tell
women these things why don't they take
it on board so I guess be confused
because I've had this conversation with
women my age women that are younger and
I would let them know that listen
this is your Prime use it to the best of
your ability to get the best that you
can attract now but for some strange
reason they think this is my time to
play and have fun and then when they get
older that's when they start to get
that's what the language changes and it
gets bitter and but I I would say that
women
are hard of hearing
yeah they're hard-headed I'm I'm that's
just me is that the mother woman
in general are hard-headed like I would
say modern women especially women
generally yeah so it's like
this manisfair space red pill space has
existed for a certain amount of years
and when men in this space have spoken
this way women have said oh he said this
he said that he's they're not listening
and and the thing is it's not like we're
saying anything that's quote unquote to
my to my personal thing I I don't think
we're saying anything that's outlandish
no we're all Revolution or revolutionary
we're saying the things that men
actually think but women have been so
used to listening to their girlfriends
like women live in an echo chamber where
they go the echo chamber girls just
their girlfriends I mean we have a male
dating coach like the Derek Jenks or
whatever his name is Derek Jackson yeah
the Steve Harvey's yeah yeah yeah like
and we just have condition shouldn't
even like men they call their daughters
what a princess why is she a princess
average chick yeah
like it's true because
men
she deserves the world why women women
live in an echo chamber with their
girlfriends and with society and that
Society tells them you are the best you
are amazing you that you can do no wrong
right and so that's why when you do the
the on street if you do like an
on-street interview woman are you a 10
yeah I'm a 10. you've done it Pearl
right everyone's a 10. and that's the
crew if you've seen an actual eight nine
or ten you will think twice before you
call yourself right like
if you're a real eight nine or ten
you've been getting paid just for being
hot now if I was to ask Eddie Eddie what
would you rate yourself
I thought it's 6.5 but my personality
takes me to seven okay see and the thing
is to expect in his chest but the thing
is that is something as a man that we
know like we know our level because you
know what when we're around our guys we
know we have a group of guys and we know
the guys that get the girls you know the
guys and we know the guys that kind of
don't get the girls but you know the
guys who get it easy we know the
grafters and the guys are getting
nothing right exactly and so when but
the thing is women also know that but
they don't say it now they lie like when
you ask a girl who's the ugly friend
right now my friend my friend oh you
didn't listen he's the ugly friend this
is it like women lie to each other they
constantly lie to each other and this is
why they are able to all of them sit in
a room and say oh yeah I'm a 10. but you
know when you go out on a Friday night
Saturday night you know the ones that
aren't getting the attention
I think you'll do that on purpose they
purposely chill with girls they know
they're more attractive them so that
they keep up more the attention that was
in the 1950s dating advice they were
there's like 1920s dating advice and it
said you basically get hotter friends so
you can get their leftovers
like
women know who the ugly friend is but
they won't tell them that they're ugly
friend do I look good in this dress no
girl you look amazing
don't lie to her
that like that's what women do they just
lie to their friends they always do they
they and the thing is we can speak like
this until we're blue in the face
they're still gonna do it that The
Sisterhood is a thing okay I'm gonna
take a second I'm gonna read as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible